hey youtubers it's Charlie fear The
Walking Dead is back this is gonna be my
episode 3 video and it seems like we're
you know even though things are going
out of control their biggest threat
isn't the walkers the biggest threat
right now seems like it's actually
Travis and real quick reminder new round
of the giveaway starts now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video just give
up for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet so here we go starting with
top five moments number five the mob vs.
Los Angeles so as you can see like there
are clearly walkers in the street
chewing on people as the mobs going
crazy which is nobody paying any
attention so within about 24 hours I
would be willing to bet that the
majority of all those people that are
looting are gonna be walkers themselves
he can't feel too bad about it because
they look like they're dumbasses anyway
[ __ ] goes crazy should you a start
tipping cards over and lighting stuff on
fire or be try to get the hell out
anybody that just chose a is
automatically marked for death the
really important thing here though is
Daniel's wife gets trapped she very
clearly is gonna be the next person to
die getting even the most minor of
infections during a Walking Dead episode
be at the main series of this spinoff is
like the worst possible thing that could
happen to you because it's not like
you're dying quickly you're gonna live
for a while as you get sicker and sicker
and sicker and then eventually turn and
if you're gonna go I mean you might as
well go quick moving out to number four
the Salazar versus Travis's family like
that the tension between them is just
starting to rise and rise you kind of
see this running theme through the
entire episode where Daniels philosophy
and Travis's philosophy we're starting
to butt heads and like I said at the
beginning of the video it seems like
Travis is actually the biggest threat to
the group right now maybe he should be
the next person to die I really like the
way they're portraying the Daniel
character right now because he's not
evil at all he just he knows what's
coming and he knows that the good people
are gonna die first that's our neighbor
she's just sick
leave her alone don't do anything that
you can't take back famous last words
but no I don't think that Travis is
gonna die right away I just think they
want to present some conflict within the
group like some people will realize
what's going on really fast it'll take a
lot longer for the gears to turn in
other people's heads Travis and Alicia
are like at the bottom of the group
right now in terms of Walker awareness
moving on to number 3 up to the top of
Walker awareness you have Madison and
Eliza they had this great scene together
where it was like hey if I go bad make
sure you and me don't make Travis do it
this actually reminded me of when Laurie
died if you remember during the walkie
dead main series Rick was not the person
to end up killing Laurie she'd given
birth to Judith and she was slowly dying
Carl ended up being the one to do the
job
Madison's thought was is that it would
break Travis like it would just
completely crush him and brick kind of
was crushed when he found out that
Laurie was dead he was just completely
catatonic for a little while that was
really only part of the scene though I
just I love the relationship these two
women have you know Travis makes the
kind of the dumb joke about having two
wives in the house but they're two of
the most smartest people in the group
right now and Liza has some medical
training that was with that whole deal
about her talking about becoming a
doctor eventually was you know obviously
now we're in the apocalypse so she's not
going to medical school anytime soon but
it sounds like she does have some
rudimentary medical training that's like
the show's way of telling you that she
is useful to the group so she's probably
not gonna die right away she's not
overpowered but she's not useless the
most useless person right now is Daniels
wife with the crushed ankle moving
that's number two The Walking Dead pays
homage to The Shining with the big maze
I know a lot of you were shaking your
fist on Twitter about I bet them jumping
into that crazy maze of death the only
reason they did that was to get the
shotgun from their neighbor but they
used it for dramatic tension if you've
never seen the Jack Nicholson shiny the
Stanley Kubrick version he chases him
around this snowy hedge maze and that's
all I could think about when they dove
into their neighbor's yard I try not to
be too hard on characters like the
Patrick neighbor when he finds his wife
and he goes to hug her even though he
sees that she is just like completely
cranked out you have to remember this is
like the early days of the Apocalypse so
you got to weed out all the stupid
people but I really did like the jump
scare with the military at the end and
the idea that even though they saved the
husband either they took him off and
shot him or they you know quote-unquote
quarantined him with a bunch of other
crazy people and he'll end up getting
turned no matter what which actually
kind of leads nicely to my number one
WTF moment the military moves in
arguably trapping them inside their
neighborhood even though it seems like
they're rescuing them anytime a
character is like things will get better
and ominous music is playing overhead
you know that things are definitely not
gonna get better I mean even if you
hadn't seen the main series you would
totally get that I like the way earlier
in the episode - that like one of the
other neighbors is wheeling his trash
out to the curb
like like no big deal just another day
Nick's out trying to steal drugs from
the other neighbors houses you see the
plane fly overhead the big surprise for
me actually too was that that plane
didn't blow up midair but if it wasn't
clear it seems like what they're moving
towards is more of like a martial law
situation where military commanders move
in and turn it into a police state
Daniel had that line where he said it's
already too late as they were marking
the houses those were just the houses of
the people that were infected what's
probably happened is as the military is
gonna be like Shane not hesitating in
sacrificing people they think are lost
no matter what their chances of recovery
are so like if the military gets their
hands on Daniel's wife they'll probably
like all right you go sit over here
we're gonna help you in like a week or
two and she'll end up turning anyway you
guys can let me know the who do you
think is actually gonna die next and who
do you think is the weakest link in the
group right now like do you think that
Travis is actually the biggest threat to
the group just because it seems like all
of his decisions are terrible no let's
not burn the body now let's wait till
tomorrow morning when the military moves
in and prevents us from going anywhere
really good news though there aren't
gonna be any more breaks before The
Walking Dead Season six starts so we're
gonna get like the next three episodes
of fear The Walking Dead each week and
then we'll get the premiere of Walking
Dead Season six if you're fan of talking
dead - they'll bring that back whenever
season six starts like they're not doing
talking dead for each episode of fear
The Walking Dead there hasn't been a ton
of new season six footage but if they
drop any I'll totally post it I'm gonna
try and get my Q&A for this out tomorrow
so leave all your WTF questions about
the episode just in case you guys need
to catch up you can click here for my
episode 2 video and all my other Walking
Dead Season 6 videos and you can click
here for this week's Game of Thrones
bonus video all about duncan egg thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow